vous étiez ministre de l'immigration
quand cet accord était historique à on
va le dire a été peaufinée en 2002 il y
avait un contexte particulier qu'il
justifiait à l'époque est important de
rappeler pourquoi et une entente
c'est très important parce que faut se
rappeler que c'était après des
événements du 11 septembre
on parlait même de créer
une barrière une double frontière du
côté des américains c'était de trouver
un équilibre entre l'ouverture et la
vigilance donc on voulait demeurer
canadien avoir notre propre système au
niveau de l'immigration c'est important
parce qu'on est un des pays les plus
généreux généreux mais peu naïf et puis
c'est clair que également on avait un
flux énorme qui faisait en sorte que on
avait on dirait parcours dure on avait
il y avait énormément de deux cores et
puis il y avait la pression on demandait
même un autre élément d'appel vous
souvenez alors on a dû mais il fallait
être vigilant
c'était primordial monsieur coderre
jeudi d'engorger le système au canada il
y avait des files possible quelles
étaient les garanties quant au respect
des droits de la personne
bah écoutez la première chose c'est que
de toute façon on avait signé du canada
la convention de genève de 1951
les américains avaient signé également
le protocole de 1967 qui était un peu la
même chose que 51 des nations unies au
niveau des réfugiés donc on a dit nous
sommes deux pays sur le commissaire de
le haut-commissaire des réfugiés étaient
tout à fait d'accord avec ça également
des nations unies et puis on a eu
finalement c'est tentant il faut se
rappeler la que ce contexte là au niveau
du homeland security le patriot act et
tout ça faisait en sorte qu'on voulait
conserver notre autonomie conserver
notre souveraineté nous assure également
que l'on puisse continuer à être ce pays
généreux respectueux de notre propre
protocole se tient de ce tiers pays sûrs
pour nous était là c'était la façon très
dynamique
sauf qu'aujourd'hui la juge écrit très
clairement que les états unis ne peuvent
plus être considérée comme un pays sûr
et le jugement sera beau quand même se
donne un peu d'air sur des témoignages
assez assez concret des détentions
arbitraires des conditions de détention
déplorables des femmes des enfants vous
répondez quoi ah ça c'est un show deux
choses la première c'est que la force de
cette entente c'est qu'on a un pouvoir
d'extension donc à l'époque on disait on
veut conserver notre propre politique
étrangère si une situation avec tel ou
tel pays parce que pour nous les
migrations cd coop particulier c'est pas
juste des coques par rapport à tel ou
tel pays
donc on a dit on établit les mesures
d'exception aux mains de sites pour les
enfants au même type pour les femmes
seules et puis on pouvait de toute façon
le ministre de l'immigration a un
pouvoir discrétionnaire mais a situation
extraordinaire mesures extraordinaires
que j'ai appliqué moi même donc à ce
moment-là sur sa première étape
mais face aux états unis rappelez-vous
comme maire quand j'ai parlé des villes
sanctuaire je travaillait de concert
avec le maire garcetti de los angele
rahm emmanuel qui était maire de chicago
est aussi l'ancien maire de l'ancien
chef de cabinet d'obama ou d'un bill de
blasio new york
et puis on faisait de toute façon il ya
une réalité politique au niveau des
états unis et ce contrepoids pouvait
faire en sorte que de toute façon on
pouvait pas lier l'autre élément oubliez
pas que la première chose le premier
décret de trois ans était sur
l'interdiction d'entrée il a été débouté
également là
au donc à ce moment là je pense qu'il
faut faire un petit peu attention c'est
pas parfait mais si on veut un équilibre
entre l'ouverture et la vigilance
moi j'aime mieux avoir une entente qui
quoique imparfaite et respectueuse des
valeurs intrinsèques des valeurs
universelles de du protocole de la
convention de genève que pas avoir
d'entente vin parce que la cour demande
de l'invalidé est ce que le canada selon
vos anciens ministres de l'immigration
ancien maire de montréal qui a vécu les
pressions que les villes ont vécu quand
les gens décident de contourner cette
entente est d'entrer clandestinement au
canada est ce que le canada puisse
permettre de se retirer de cette entente
à mon avis non alors la première chose
qu'ils doivent faire c'est d'aller en
appel alors je comprends qu'elle mérite
blair de toute façon vont vous regardez
ça ça cette fois les conséquences d'une
telle entente
ben les conséquences ça veut dire qu'à
ce moment là pour moi là ce qui est
clair c'est que tous ceux qui vont
passer par la frontière terrestre à ce
moment là on est obligé de les prendre
donc on doit passer donc on va alourdir
le système écoutez on est on est
généreux don de 55 mille réfugiés je
comprends que 80 millions de déracinés
d'un nom le canada 55 mille réfugiés
cette année l'année dernière les
etats-unis ont eu 45 me c'est une des
premières fois où il y en a moins
mais il ya quelque chose d'important qui
va arriver c'est en avance d'un
élections alors débarrassez vous de tram
puis on n'a pas revu la réalité pour moi
c'est que ça va créer une pression
énorme sur le système ça va
déséquilibrer l'ensemble cerveau crée
encore plus de drames sociaux à ce
moment alors parallèlement on peut quand
même passer des messages parlé avec
l'ensemble de nos collègues des autres
pays de le mener campagne peut passer
des messages au secrétaire d'état
il ya des réalités mexicaine qui ne sont
pas des réalités canadienne
et puis vous avez vu aussi l'énorme
pression au niveau des villes quand on
parle des étudiants étrangers
il ya une dualité de main d'oeuvre
également aux états unis.le donc ces
gens là sont réelles elles sont
intégrées au niveau du milieu de travail
donc ça soit pas du jour au lendemain
cette affaire le ton on se dit que
l'invalidation pourrait se faire dans 6
mois donc on parle en 2021 y voir une
élection entre temps j'espère que des
gens vont bien assumer leur démocratie
mais pas réellement je pense que le
canada doit ou bien mettre l'accent sur
ces mesures d'extension ou bien de toute
façon aller en appel et aller jusqu'en
cour suprême avec ça merci beaucoup
monsieur codage rappelle que vous avez
négocié cette entente en 2002 merci
beaucoup merci à leur argent